voilà nous nous retrouvons maintenant
sous cette pyramide merci monsieur le
Président d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et puis nous gardons nos
manteaux parce c'est vrai qu'il ne fait
pas très frais alors cette première
question c'est à propos de l'origine du
projet il y a une vive polémique pas
complètement terminée d'ailleurs on a
employé des mots comme sacrilège on
avait dit à l'époque et est-ce que vous
n'avez pas eu je dirais un petit vertige
au moment du choix final car cela vous
engageit nous aussi français pour des
siècles sans aucun doute je ne me suis
pas décidé comme cela
aisément j'avais la conviction qu'il
fallait que le musée du l'ouvre car il
s'agit de
ça devint un lieu où l'on aimerait aller
voir les œuvres admirables qui s'y
trouvent et il avait pas moyen l'accès
les commodités la présentation des
œuvres ça ne marchait pas alors comment
faire j'ai donc consulté les architectes
qui ont étudié de multiples projets et
celui de Monsieur pe m'est apparu comme
le plus rationnel le meilleur et
peut-être le plus beau oui mais c'est la
décision
difficile non mais j'ai l' je reconnais
par rapport à l'œuvre du temps
construction passée à cet ensemble de
d'œuvre maîtresse qui se trouve au cœur
de Paris c'est un problème qui m'a donné
beaucoup de soucis et si je me suis
décidé c'est vraiment en conscience
monsieur le Président est-ce le projet
culturel dont vous êtes le plus fier
aujourd'hui oh disons que j'ai certain
une prédilection parce que ça vient de
loin ça faisait déjà longtemps avant
d'être président de la République que je
me disais ça va pas cette cour Napoléon
où nous sommes ce squir avec ses arbres
lépreux c'est espèce de parking F la
nuit je pense que on devait hésiter à
s'y promener noir tout ça pour ce beau
musée à côté de ce beau musée il fallait
changer il fallait absolument adapter le
temps moderne aux monuments anciens
voilà voilà ce que ça donne et ben
justement monsieur le Président quand
vous avez dit oui à Monsieur pay vous
aviez une idée de son projet bien sûr
vous l'imaginiez mais est-ce que ça
correspond à ce que vous imaginez oui
oui c'est veut dire que plusieurs grands
architectes me paraissaient souhaitaable
et finalement si j'ai arrêté mon choix
sur
pay cette ce Chinois américain c'est
parce que j'avais vu à in inton et à
Boston deux de ces Avre maîtresses un
musée en particulier et vraiment c'était
admirable c'est ça vous a dit c'est
l'homme de la situation après une
conversation je me suis rendu compte que
qu'il était l'amoureux non seulement de
de l'ouvre mais de l'histoire de la
France et que jamais il ne commettrait
la faute je dirais même le crime de de
nuire à l'ensemble dans lequel nous
sommes alors il y a une tradition
présidentielle on peut dire ça
de laisser quelque chose à l'histoire je
parle de Monsieur Pompidou du Président
giscardestin vous avec le grand lou la
tête desfense l'opéra Basle alors bien
sûr c'est pour la France c'est pour la
grandeur de la France mais est-ce qu'il
y a pas une part de prestige personnel
non vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez
naturellement penser mais je crois que
seul un président de la République
dispose du temps 7
ans qui permett de
décider reprendre et de mener à bien
souvent il faut plus de 7 ans mais quand
le train est lancé peut pas s'arrêter
monsieur le Président est-ce que vous
aimeriez qu'on parle du style mitéran je
veux dire à travers les choix culturels
que vous avez fait on peut dégager
quelques grandes lignes vous aimez les
traits très beau les les choses très
épuré est-ce qu'on peut parler de vos
style qu'on pourrait opposer certains
journaux l'ont fait ce matin à votre
personnalité qu'on dit plus caché moins
transparente par exemple que cette
pyramide si on disait ou qu'il y a un
style mitéran j'en seraai flatté je
l'avoue mais il n'y en a pas car
l'ensemble des grands projets relève du
choix de juris internationaux ou
nationaux et si en
effet j'ai pris part à la décision et
même si j'ai pris la décision finale
dans chaque cas c'est aussi parce que
j'avais un certain goût pour les formes
géométrique pururequ que ce que je dis
là n'est déjà pas vrai de l'opéra
bastique mais il n'y avait pas de projet
en en concurrence qui répondent à mes
définitions en revanche voyez ce qui se
passe avec la Geode euh à la Vilette
dont je ne suis d'ailleurs pas l'auteur
voyez ce qui se passe ici voyez
l'arche du la future installation de la
défense c'estàdire un arc de triomp de
plus dans la grande perspective qui va
jusqu'à la terrasse de Saint-Germain
cela correspond je crois que les formes
pures et simples me plaisent plus que
les autres monsieur le président vous
vous êtes sûrement interrogé plus que
quiconque sur le pouvoir et en voyant
cela ce matin avec patricien et d'autres
personnes qui ont visité on s'est dit
mais est-ce que c'est pas là la
manifestation la plus symbolique du
pouvoir se dire ici dans cette cour dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure le soir pas
pas très tranquille et bien moi je
décide de faire quelque chose est-ce que
c'est pas ça le pouvoir c'est une forme
déterminante du pouvoir et pour avoir
dès mon adolescence puisque j'éta des
étudiants à Paris pour avoir beaucoup
euh circulait je me suis beaucoup
promené dans Paris dans ma tête c'est
vrai à tout moment je rebâtissais ah oui
déjà oui oui déjà bon je ne pensais pas
que j'en aurais l'occasion et quand j'en
ai eu l'occasion je l'ai pas raté oui
parce que dans les livres d'histoire
qu'est-ce qu'on va retenir est-ce qu'on
va dire je ne sais pas il y a eu telle
loi sous le sepéna ou 14 années du
président miteran parce qu'une loi ça
peut se défaire mais tandis que là on
dira pourquoi 14 allez vite B quand une
non mais une loi ça peut se défaire
tandis que ça ça bouge pas est-ce que
vous travaillez pour les livres
d'histoire en faisant ça vous pensez à
il y a autre chose il y a le fait que
nous sommes précisément au cœur de
l'histoire de France puisque c'est à
côté tout à côté que se trouve la la
tour de Philippe Auguste la tour de
Louvre c'est là que on peut le dire le
royaume s'est fait c'est là que la
France s'est faite c'est autour de de ce
bâtiment là cette tour de lour que
Philippe Auguste avec le saut Royal a pu
marquer qu'il y avait l'unité du royaume
et tous les ordres partaient de là je
pense que c'est assez exaltant de penser
qu' par la suite
le palais des tunery aujourd'hui détruit
et qui a marqué à partir de Catherine
de6 toute une nouvelle série de
construction admirable et puis tout ce
qui a fait finalement l'endroit où nous
sommes c'est en effet très exaltant pour
l'esprit que d'y ajouter même avec
modestie parce qu'après tout je ne
prétends pas être celui qui décide de ce
qui est l'esthétique en France mais d'
vooir contribuer bien alors monsieur le
Président nous allons maintenant sortir
du du cadre du Grand lou nous allons
regarder ensemble si vous le souhaitez
pour nous intéresser je disais tout à
l'heure au sepénat culturel hein alors
le sepénat culturel du président
mitteran avec un certain nombre de
grands projets dont certains comme
celui-ci sont bien avancés alors parmi
ces exemples des réalisations à la
Villette le ministère des Finances à
Bery l'opéra de la Bastille la tête
défense dont nous avons parlé voici avec
Jean péieux la présentation de ces
grands trapaux cette vue prestigieuse
sur Paris les visiteurs pourront la
découvrir à partir du 14 juillet 89 du
toit de l'Arche de la Défense la plus
grande partie des bureaux de l'arche ont
été vendu au privé mais c'est dans les
35 étages de la parois Sud que Pierre
meigneri ici installera les 2000
fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'Équipement le 14 juillet 89 c'est
aussi la date de l'ouverture de l'Opéra
de la Bastille dont les travaux ont
retrouver leur rythme normal après le
compromis passé entre le ministre de
l'Économie et celui de la culture choix
de la transparence sur le quartier de la
Bastille de la part de l'architecte hot
les visiteurs apprécieront sans doute la
qualité des espaces ici les les galeries
et les foyers et les espaces aussi de la
grande salle de 2700 places l'inconnu
demeure par contre pour la deuxème salle
ici que le gouvernement souhaite vendre
au privés comme les ateliers de décor
les retards construction et attribution
auront entraîné en tout cas quelques 200
millions de dépassements surcou aussi du
même ordre à Bery où se poursuivent les
travaux de construction du futur
ministère des Finances plus de 5000
fonctionnaires doivent s'y installer
1300 pour l'instant occupe les lieux la
Direction Générale des Impôts mobilier
adapté bureau ultra moderne et surtout
informatisé c'est la vitrine attendue de
la technologie française notez aussi ce
système de chariot suspendu pour la
transmission des dossiers les
fonctionnaires encore rel l'ouvr en tout
cas aimeraient bien en
profiter nous syndicat nous pensons
enfin d'après les les réponses que nous
avons des gens les enquêtes que nous
avons faites que la majorité des gens
ont hâte que le que le déménagement se
fasse et en totalité le plus rapidement
possible et qu'il n'y ait plus de ces
caprices finalement qui font que c'est
constamment retardé que que les gens
sont dans incertitude qui qui bon qui
sont angoissés finalement pour l'heure
Édouard Baladur se maintient au Louvre
de l'identité du prochain ministre des
Finances en tout cas dépend l'occupation
plus ou moins rapide de Bercy et partant
la libération du palais du lour alors le
projet Grand Louvre comprend
l'agrandissement mais aussi la
rénovation de certaines parties de
l'actuelle musée or cela suppose que le
le ministre le ministère des Finances
qui est là tout près veuille bien Ben se
déplacer mais alors est-ce que vous
considérez monsieur président que pour
autant le chantier est en
panne il a été retardé et il a coûté
plus cher
mais ce projet est inélictable désormais
au point où nous en sommes et je m'en
réjouis c'est la marche de l'histoire on
ne peut pas aller compte on peut pas
aller compte et quand des millions de
visiteurs seront venus par là cela
s'imposera de telle sorte que les petits
embarras administratifs s'évanouiront
monsieur le Président tout de même
est-ce qu'il ne faut pas accélérer les
choses je veux dire est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que le futur fut président de
la République devrait accélérer le
départ du ministère des Finances qui
occupe une ail du Louvre je le pense car
l'œuvre ne sera complète qu'après cela
et l'on peut déjà imaginer ce que seront
les cours de l'actuel ministère réservé
à des très belles œuvres de sculpture
avec le débouché sur le palais royal au
travers d'une admirable porte qui est la
porte Richelieu donc si vous étiez
président de la République vous
accelleriez les choses sans aucun doute
vous vous en parlerai à votre suc
bienend la Commission en tout cas
monsieur le Président une question qui
va vous paraître naïve mais certains se
demandent si ça coûte cher et si c'était
vraiment prioritaire de faire tout
cela ça coûte non pas comme d'autres le
disent milliard mais une quinzaine de
milliards réparti sur de 7 à 10 ans donc
il faut découper cela en tranche pour
l'introduire dans le
budget
il faut savoir aussi ce qu'on ignore
trop souvent c'est que j'ai hérité de
plusieurs de ces projets parmi les plus
important la
Vette
or et l'Institut du monde arabe sont des
projets conçu par monsieurtin que j'ai
réalisé mais qui éta déjà décidé dans
leur principe et même dans leur futur
unité architectural cela représente
environ déjà 40 % de ces 15 milliards
j'y a ajouté d'autres grands projets
vous les avez cité tout à l'heure on va
sélectionner si vous voulez pour la
rapidité du discours actuellement
l'Arche de la Défense l'Opéra Bastille
et le Grand Louvre bon je ne pense pas
que ce soit trop cher par rapport au
gain qu'on tirera la France et cela a
représenta aussi des milliers d'emplois
dans des métiers en péril qui sont les
métiers d'art je crois que final ement
c'est un grand bénéfice j'ajoute que
cela devient rentable en même temps
savez-vous qu's il y a chaque jour
environ une moyenne de 13000
visiteurs combien viendront ici Monsieur
miteran et les vieilles pierres parlons
de qualifier ainsi le patrimoine de la
France mais certains disent au fond le
Président il n'aime que créer des choses
faire des grands travaux il a un peu
délaissé les églises les cathédrales et
cetera cétait même dit à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale tout fait mais
c'est même dit souvent sur viens les
tribunes chaque soir actuellement mais
ce n'est pas vrai les crédits attribués
au patrimoine sont passés sur la
législature précédente de plus de 500
millions à plus de 800 millions et
d'autre part j'ai en effet avec le
ministre de la Culture et Monsieur
Jacques Lang j'ai entrepris la
restauration du patrimoine au travers de
la cathédrale d'Amien de la cathédrale
de reins de la cathédrale de bourge de
la cathédrale de Bordeaux de la
cathédrale de Strasbourg vous vous
souvenez sans doute de cette pièce
populaire à Strasbourg quand enfin on a
pu achever ce qui avait é entrepris dans
cette belle cathédrale bon ce ne sont
que quelques exemples on a créé quelques
1000 bibliothèques on a rénové plus de
100 musées de province bon j'arrête là
mon récit et on a aussi engagé des
travaux
nouveaux vous savez bien l'immeubles de
la bande dessinée centre boulem de
photographie à har de la musique à
Lyon les archives du travail à rou j'en
pass je pas être trop long dans mon
énumération je dis simplement que c'est
une critique injuste assurément en
raison de la modicité des crédits bien
que nous ayons avec Jacques Lang doublé
les sommes les crédits des Affaires
Culturelles évidemment on peut pas tout
faire à la fois par exemple je me suis
longtemps plein auprès du ministre
auprès des premier ministres de ce que
l'on n pas fait ce qu'il fallait faire
pour le Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle
finalement ça a été entrepris mais j'ai
dû me battre pendant moins 3 ans mais
comment ça se passe dans ces caslà quand
vous rencontrez le Premier ministre vous
lui dites al prier
ministre
1986 la modernisation nécessaire de ce
musé a commencé à cette époque mais il
m'a fallu aussi insister beaucoup pour
convaincre les prédécesseurs de Monsieur
chir voilà ce que je peux dire peut pas
tout faire à la fois alors forcément
quand on veut critiquer on peut toujours
relever que ceci n'a pas été
fait je je le concède qui ferait mieux
voilà le problème monsieur le Président
nous arrivons au terme de cet entretien
euh est-ce que deux trois petites
questions qui dépassent un peu le cadre
de de ce grand lour est-ce que vous avez
l'impression en lisant les sondages ou
autres que les Français sont un peu
agacés ou que vous jouez avec leur nerf
parce que vous ne vous déclarez pas
suffisamment tôt à leur avis ah bon ça
c'est une autre affaire permettez-moi de
vous dire quand même un mot sur la
conversation principale que nous venons
de tenir un mot simplement pour dire que
je suis de ceux qui croient profondément
et ceux qui le croient se retrouvent
dans tout les camps heinant tout les
formation politique mais je suis de ceux
qui croi que une politique culturelle
est à la base de tout autre politique
qu'il faut que les Français se
retrouvent dans leur histoire dans leur
art dans leur passer pour qu'ils sachent
mieux avoir l'ambition de leur avenir
c'est pourquoi j'ai beaucoup tenu à ce
que la culture apparaisse comme une des
actions
principales des gouvernements auxquels
j'ai pu adresser disons des conseils
vous avez fini votre travail mon
président mais de ce point de vue là je
veux dire je n'ai pas fini mon travail
je vois où vous voulez en venir par
rapport à ce que nous voyons puisque
nous sommes encore sur un chantier ce
que je peux dire c'est que spécialement
par rapport au au Grand Louvre le relais
a été bien pris par l'actuel ministre de
laculture il a été bien pris faut
cononnaître et de ce fait monsieur
Léotard a permis que les retards qui
s'annonçaient soient réduits il faut
admettre ce qui est la continuité dans
ce domaine à jouer alors vous voulez
revenir à votre question que je crois
avoir compris je oui je suppose que vous
l'avez deviné et même comprise bon je ne
sais pas si les Français
s'impatientent ce que je pense c'est ils
comprennent très bien que je fasse mon
métier de Président c'est pourquoi ils
m'ont élu il y a bientôt 7 ans que je le
fasse jusqu'à la date raisonnable qui
doit normalement me conduire à la fin de
mon mandat c'est sur ce terme de
raisonnable que l'appréciation peut
varier mais je fais mon métier président
j'étais encore hier à Bruxelles pour
lotane quelques temps auparavant enfin
je vais et je viens pour des choses qui
concernent la vie nationale et je
répéterai que je répète partout si je ne
le fais pas est-ce que l'État se
trouvera en désirance il a le Premier
ministre le Premier ministre fait du
travail mais il est quand même très pris
par sa situation de
candidat quand on est candidat on peut
pas tout faire ça voulez dire je pense
que
c'estile je pense que c'est difficile
quand on est
candidat je suis habitué il y a
parfaitement le droit de l'être je ne le
critique pas du tout pour cela je dis
simplement que mon rôle moi est
différent et comme je l'ai souvent dit
j'ai peur que les téléspectateurs ne se
lassent de cela ou je suis pas candidat
je veux garder mon autorité le plus
longtemps possible notamment sur la
scène internationale je le suis en pend
quand même 4 mois à l'avance 3 mois à
l'avance même 2 mois à l'avance mois là
on arrive bientôt on arrive on arrive
peu à peu c'est
pourquoi cette nouvelle que vous désirez
connaître vous n'attendrez pas très
longtemps avant de la prendre décion la
connaissez cette nouvelle ma décision
est prise décision est prise votre choix
est fait naturellement monsieur le
Président votre frère Robert nous a
confié récemment il était notre invité
parce qu'il vient d'écrire un livre sur
votre famille que ce sujet précisément
était abordé au cours de réunion
familial à l'Élysée qu'il vous disait
pardon mais c'est son expression il faut
y aller François voilà il vous parle
comme ça et puis il n'est pas le seul
dans votre famille alors je sais que
vous avez l'esprit de famille est-ce que
ce genre de réflexion peuvent euh infu
ou l'ensemble de mes frères et sœurs et
de leurs parents tout ça c'est un une
représentation très fidèle de ce qu'est
la société française hein bon alors ils
me disent la même chose il y a pas
beaucoup de gens de droite monsieur
président s dans votre famille il y en a
il y a de tout il y a tout ce que vous
voulez revenir à la politique toujours
et bien je leur réponds comme à vous à
la même chose donc il enen savent pas
plus très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président peut-on prendre rendez-vous
alors là que vous soyez ou non candidat
que vous soyez ou non candidat à la
présidence de la République pour le
journal de 13h sur Antenne 2 qui suivra
l'annonce de votre décision ça je peux
pas vous le promettre non je peux pas
vous promre inv je vous remercie en tout
cas de votre gentillesse on vous invite
maisain je peux pas vous dire de toute
manière quoi qu' arrive quelle que soit
la décision ah oui oui bien sûr car je
ne je n'offrirai pas de de faille dans
mon raisonnement c'est ce que j'ai CR
compr donc quel que soit la décision je
viendrai en tout cas2 si vous le voulez
mais quand à vous garantir le jour et
l'heure non non d'accord en tout cas
bien merci monsieur le Président
j'espère que vous n'z pas merci beaucoup
nous allons continuer l'actualité mdecin